hey guys it's me Debbie with the baby on
the way I've had to seriously cut back
on my mojitos and I'd be missing out on
my weekly girls night happy hour the
struggle is real people but that doesn't
mean I'm not gonna get up in your health
business and tell you all my greatest
tips for avoiding that nasty hangover
let's talk booze people always a
pleasure Deb while I do miss my little
drinky drink at the end of the week
what I don't miss for sure is the
hangovers now to get a little sciency on
you when alcohol is broken down it does
so by two different enzymes and that
produces acetate and acetaldehyde so one
of the byproducts acetaldehyde is a
toxic substance that when it built up in
our body it produces some of those
unpleasant symptoms
unfortunately the research suggests
there's not a whole lot we can do about
this except for maybe just drink less
but I'm definitely interested to hear
some of your tips Deb so let's hear them
now that that boring sciency stuff is
out of the way let's talk about some of
my best hangover cures so after a while
Debbie can tonight I will not go
anywhere until I have an extra large
coffee with triple Splenda in my hand
it's basically my BFF yes it's true how
much everyone's go-to beverage to cure a
hangover is usually coffee I think we
gravitate towards coffee because it
helps to target the fatigue that we feel
after a really long night Oh however if
you overdo it on the caffeine you might
end up irritating your gut a little bit
and let's be real it's probably not
feeling so great as is so instead of the
coffee go for the h2o instead well I was
gonna say water I saw up a massive jug
with filtered water and I keep that by
my bed all day gotta get that h2o fixed
definitely Deb water is always the best
choice when it comes to replenishing
those fluids and correcting dehydration
because when you're dehydrated that's
when you get the worst hangover symptoms
so I always recommend that people drink
plenty of water before during and after
a boozy night out also staying hydrated
is a really good way to help your
kidneys out so they can flush out some
of those nasty toxins like that
acetaldehyde
that's really gonna help to keep you
symptom-free well on top of that I hear
it's all about the electrolytes so I
always stock up on a huge amount of
Gatorade the night before hey future Deb
to the rescue in addition to losing
fluids our bodies also experience a loss
of electrolytes so a lot of people will
use sports drinks or some pickle juice
as a way to replenish the electrolytes
like sodium magnesium potassium and
calcium now we see this all the time
with let's say athletes who use sports
drinks to replenish the electrolytes
that they loser through their sweat
however whether or not this works does a
hangover cure is still unclear
I definitely don't support the use of
pickle juice because let's be real all
that vinegar and the acid can definitely
irritate an already probably achy gut so
if you don't have sports drinks on hand
try to look for foods that are rich in
potassium and magnesium so things like
bananas dates figs raisins nuts cereal
and dairy products well then I can
finally gain the strength to leave my
bed I make the trek to the greasiest
diner I can find oh it is not a pretty
walk for me and my girls however I body
is needing some pancakes and I know what
you're thinking
Debbie and carbs whether this is the one
exception I make when I ride the carb
train ah yes a greasy breakfast is
probably one of the most common hangover
cures the idea here is that when we
drink a lot of alcohol our blood sugar
levels tanked so by having a high carb
meal our blood sugars can normalize and
we can feel a lot better however the
research in this area is pretty fuzzy
and it's unsure whether or not a hearty
breakfast can cure a hangover once and
for all however does make sense to have
a good satiating meal before you go out
drinking so that it can slow down the
alcohol absorption be sure to include a
little bit of fat in that meal because
fat is slower to digest so by the time
that you start drinking the fat in your
gut will help to slow down the alcohol
absorption well at least boon I also
always need some eggs I don't know I
read somewhere that eggs contain some
substance to help to eliminate some kind
of toxin I don't know that's the science
ease I'm gonna get you're definitely on
the right track Dib so eggs are a great
source of cysteine which is an amino
acid that actually helps to bind the
acetaldehyde to help eliminate the toxin
so it may help to reduce your symptoms
I also heard something about oatmeal
that it can help with like our blood
sugar or something you're totally right
a hot bowl of oatmeal is great to
provide you with the vitamins and
minerals that you need after a big night
out it's also great to provides us with
that satiety factor and it helps to slow
down and normalize our blood sugar
levels so that we feel less dizzy and
nauseous the key here is to make sure
that you're dressing your oatmeal bowl
up with lots of nourishing nuts and
fruits that we're getting in lots of
vitamins and minerals well my last tip
Abbey is probably one you are not gonna
like but my greatest hangover cure of
all time is a bottomless Bloody Mary oh
yes when I know brunch in with my
hashtag Squad a few rounds of Bloody
Mary's are totally in order I mean hey
if you're not bloody nearing it you're
not doing life right oh yeah this is the
oldest trick in the books
beat booze with more booze and if it
sounds ridiculous folks it's because it
really is so a lot of people believe
that the vitamins and electrolytes and
tomato juice will help to cure your
hangover
however the extra dose of liqueur
definitely will not help first of all
more alcohol is just gonna dehydrate you
further which is gonna make your
symptoms worse of course second alcohols
gonna irritate your stomach and
intestines which are probably already
feeling pretty rough and third acidic
foods like tomatoes and spicy foods like
Tabasco will further irritate your
stomach so none of these things are
gonna be doing you any favors guys you
know you're not gonna like this but
there are no real hangover cures however
there are some things that we can do to
help
like maybe avoiding an excessive amount
of alcohol next time just a thought and
of course there are some foods that may
help out the reality is the wheel cure
for hangover is time and sleep and maybe
just not drinking that much next time
well I hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below some of your
go-to hangover cures subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]